- Have you ever driven a car?
Then you've broken the law.
Have you ever sold anything on eBay?
Have you ever shared
your Netflix password?
Then you've broken the law.
Yes, there are a lot of
laws in the United States,
and every single one of you
are dirty, filthy criminals
because you have broken the law
and you might not have known it.
Studies show that the average
American breaks 473 laws
every single day.
I just made that up, but it's
probably close to the truth
because there's so many
laws in the United States
that people just can't help
but break the law sometimes.
So, let's talk about all of the ways
that you broke the law, but
probably didn't even know it.
(cheerful music)
Now, everyone knows that
in many jurisdictions
it's illegal to gamble, and
a lot of people do it anyway,
especially with friends.
But what about your
weekly at-home poker game?
Is this really, truly illegal?
Well, local laws differ but generally,
if the host accepts money,
so-called "taking a rake,"
then yes, this is actually illegal.
- I'm shocked, shocked,
to find that gambling
is going on in here.
- You're winnings, sir.
- Oh, thank you very much.
Everybody out at once.
- And often, in many places,
in order for a game to
be considered gambling,
it must involve a prize or consideration
and be determined mostly by chance.
If there's no consideration
or the game is deemed a game of skill,
then that game will be
legal in most jurisdictions.
So, what is poker?
Isn't it arguably a game of skill?
Well, defendants have made this argument
with limited success.
In Colorado, back in 2009,
Kevin Raley started a poker league
where the league kept 10% of
the entrance fee for expenses
to pay for the dealers who
were running the games.
The Colorado Bureau of Investigation did
an undercover investigation
and arrested five people
for playing Texas hold'em.
Raley was charged with illegal gambling,
but a jury acquitted him
after a professor testified
that poker was a game
of skill, not chance.
Unfortunately for Raley, the
Court of Appeals disagreed
that poker was mostly
about skill, not chance,
and the Appeals Court ruled
that the expert testimony
should have been excluded.
Now, the Colorado Supreme
Court has declined
to hear Raley's appeal.
But the bottom line is that
if your local poker host
or dealer is taking some
sort of consideration,
(dramatic music)
then that might be an illegal game
and you might have broken
the law by participating.
Now, when you've gone on the internet,
have you ever pretended to
be something that you aren't?
Well, you might have broken the law.
Catfishing of the computer kind
is defined as the
process of luring someone
into a relationship by means
of a fictional online persona.
And if you've ever seen MTV's "Catfish,"
then you know the drill.
Someone creates a
fictitious online profile,
then tricks someone else into
falling in love with them.
- You can't possibly think
it's still Katy Perry.
- I do.
- Can you just pop his bubble for a second
and tell him that he has not
been talking to Katy Perry?
- The typical catfish situation
includes stealing someone else's pictures,
often they belong to
some unsuspecting model,
and texting the target with false promises
of everlasting love.
- The one problem is he
doesn't have a cell phone,
or a landline, or a car,
or any people who know him besides me.
- Now, creating fake online profiles
definitely violates the terms and services
of most dating and social media sites,
such as OkCupid and Facebook.
But catfishing in and of itself
is not necessarily illegal.
However, some of the catfish's activities
can violate criminal law.
If the purpose of the catfishing
is to get money and gifts,
then this can be prosecuted as fraud.
If the catfish uses personal
information about their target
to get loans or credit cards,
this is probably identity theft.
If the fake identity
is used to lure minors
into a relationship, then that
act could definitely violate
child protection laws.
And although breaking U.S. copyright laws
won't land you in jail necessarily,
using someone else's photographs
might be copyright infringement,
and the Copyright Act allows the victim
to collect actual and statutory damages
for that infringement.
And if you decided to pass
yourself off as a model
using images you found on Google,
you could get in even bigger trouble
because damages for a licensed image
could be up to $150,000 per photo,
especially if the
misrepresentation was willful.
So, yeah, don't go out
there catfishing people,
even if you're trying to
become the next Chris Hansen.
- I'm Chris Hansen.
- No, you're not.
- Yes, I am.
- No you're not.
- Now, people love tiny houses,
but if you're living in a tiny house,
you might be breaking the law.
Building tiny houses is
something of a trend in the U.S.,
but these stylish Keebler
houses aren't always kosher
in the eyes of the law.
Now, the Department of Housing
and Urban Development's
newest regulations give
RVs and tiny houses
a little more breathing
room under the law,
but the regs also say that tiny
houses which rest on a skid
or foundation, or are
over 400 square feet,
must meet HUD's manufactured
housing standards
to be considered legal.
That said, whether your tiny home is legal
depends almost entirely
on how your local area
classifies tiny homes.
Some cities ban homes
under 400 square feet,
while others ban them
if they are moveable.
Yes, that's right, lots
of cities and states
love to fight high housing costs
by making it harder to build more housing.
But living in a tiny house
can also have criminal consequences
because a court can conclude
that your mobile vehicle
isn't a home at all for purposes
of the Fourth Amendment.
In California versus Carney,
the Supreme Court ruled
that the warrantless
search of a motor home
did not violate the Fourth
Amendment's guarantee
against warrantless searches and seizures.
Why? Because the court
considered it a vehicle.
The Supreme Court has
said that the Constitution
requires a lesser degree of
protection for motor vehicles
because they can move quickly
before a warrant can be obtained.
And in that particular
case, the man's motor home
wasn't in a residential area
and was licensed as a vehicle.
So, you might get it both ways.
You might be illegally
living in a tiny house
and also not receive all kinds
of constitutional protections
afforded for actual houses.
Have you ever warmed up
your car before driving off?
Well, you might have broken the law.
If you've ever lived above
the Mason-Dixon line,
then you're probably
familiar with the concept
of warming up the car.
If the wind chill is hovering around
zero degrees Fahrenheit,
then it seems like a pretty
good idea to start the car,
turn on the heater, and let
the car idle for a while
before you actually climb in.
That way you won't freeze to death.
But not so fast.
Many states have anti-idling laws.
At least 25 states ban idling
because it contributes
to air pollution, duh.
The American Transportation
Research Institute
has a full compendium
of state and local laws
that prohibit idling before
you start driving away.
And unsurprisingly, the
further north you go,
the more complicated the laws.
In Denver, for instance, you're
not supposed to idle the car
for more than five minutes an hour,
which can get you a fine of up to $1,000.
But there are exceptions to
reflect the cold weather.
If the average temperature
has been under 20 degrees
for 24 hours or it's less
than 10 degrees outside,
you can heat up your car
for as long as you want.
Your mileage may vary.
Have you ever shared your Netflix password
with someone else?
Well, then you might have broken the law.
Could sharing your Netflix password
actually violate federal law?
You bet it might possibly
theoretically do that.
The Computer Fraud & Abuse Act, or CFAA,
is a federal law that imposes
civil and criminal penalties
when a person accesses a
computer without authorization
or exceeding authorized access.
Believe it or not, federal
courts cannot agree
on whether this means it's against the law
for you to share your password.
In 2016, a split Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals
ruled that these words mean
that a person cannot access
another person's account
using that person's password
when the person has revoked
the first person's access rights.
Judge Reinhart, who
dissented in that case,
warned that a broad
interpretation of the CFAA's
in excess of authorization prong would,
"Criminalize the ordinary
conduct of millions of citizens."
And yes, that means you.
Other circuits have
ruled in similar cases,
but there is no consensus
view on when the person's use
of someone else's password is illegal.
The defendant from the Ninth Circuit case
asked the Supreme Court
to resolve the issue,
but the U.S. Solicitor
General filed a brief
for the government saying
that there wasn't really a circuit split
and that the issue was narrow
whether someone could continue
using a password after the
person revoked their permission.
The Supreme Court denied cert.
So, what now?
Many commentators have said
that the CFAA is way too broad
and criminalizes tons and tons of activity
that should not be considered illegal.
And the Supreme Court
has in fact curtailed
some of the aspects of the CFAA
with respect to police officers
and government officials.
But the question of sharing your password
remains open at this time.
So, what do you do now?
Well, you're gonna have to ask yourself
whether watching "Bridgerton"
is worth going to jail over.
And then back to gambling
because if you've ever bet on sports,
then you might have broken the law.
The rules against gambling on sports
were relaxed after the
Supreme Court's decision
in Murphy versus the NCAA.
This decision paved the way for states
to permit sports betting,
but there are still federal
laws disallowing sports betting,
and this invites all
kinds of police overreach.
For example, the Illegal
Gambling Business Act of 1970
was passed to target organized crime.
And under that law, a
gambling business is illegal
if they exceed over $2,000 of
gross revenue in a single day.
And this law is broad
enough to implicate people
who aren't part of any
organized crime organizations.
So if you or your friends
violate some local laws
against sports gambling
and wager more than $2,000
in a single day, the cops can bust you.
And in a particularly tragic case,
a Virginia detective overheard
an optometrist, Sal Culosi,
talking about betting on
college football games
with his friends.
The detective then befriended Culosi,
eventually convincing him
to bet more than $2,000
in a single day.
Then the police brought a
SWAT team to Culosi's house
and killed him in that raid.
Have you ever used someone's
Wi-Fi without permission?
Well, you might have broken the law.
Now, not all U.S.
jurisdictions make it illegal
to steal Wi-Fi, but in Sparta, Michigan,
a man was arrested for
using a cafe's Wi-Fi
to check his email while
sitting in his car.
The cafe owner didn't know it was illegal
nor did the man, but a cop
watched him do this every day
and decided it was suspicious.
Then he found the law that made,
"Unauthorized computer access," a crime.
So not only are there
issues on a federal level
with the CFAA, but
there are also all kinds
of local laws that might make
unauthorized computer access
a crime, even if there aren't any victims
in stealing that person's Wi-Fi.
Have you ever purchased
spray paint or markers?
Well, you might have broken the law.
Some states and cities
really hate graffiti.
Despite the fact that most
people who buy spray paint
have no intention of breaking the law,
the authorities have decided
that they need to stop
a certain group of people
from buying spray paint,
and those people are minors.
Now, laws banning miners
from buying paint and markers
originated in the early
1990s when disaffected youth
were wearing flannel, listening
to Public Enemy and Nirvana,
and hanging out around skate parks.
Ah, the horror!
But young people listening
to rap and grunge
freaked out city officials around America
who were absolutely certain
that these minors were
defacing public property.
Therefore, in California,
it's illegal for any person
under the age of 18 years
to purchase etching cream or
an aerosol container of paint
that is capable of defacing property.
Penalties include up to 100
hours of community service
enforced over a 90-day period.
And if you own a business
that sells paint,
you're also a target of these laws.
Quote, "Every retailer
selling or offering for sale
"in the state etching cream,"
or whatever the hell that is,
"or aerosol containers of paint
capable of defacing property
"shall post in a conspicuous
place a sign in letters
"at least three-eights
of an inch high stating:
"'Any person who maliciously defaces real
"or personal property with
etching cream or paint
"is guilty of vandalism,
"which is punishable by a
fine, imprisonment, or both.'"
These laws really haven't
had much an impact
on the presence of graffiti,
and they've been challenged
by people impacted by the law.
Fashion designer Mark Ecko
actually sued New York City
on behalf of college
and high school students
who he claimed had their
First Amendment rights
infringed upon by the city's law,
which banned the purchase
of certain materials
to people under the age of 21.
The Second Circuit ruled
that the law was overly broad
and restrictive because it barred youths
from even possessing markers
or spray paint in public
or carrying the materials
on public transportation
or in a school.
The law as written hindered
young adults' access
to materials that they needed
for lawful artistic expression.
Man, parents, they just don't understand.
Now, have you ever sold anything on eBay
and not reported your income?
If so, you have broken the law.
If you sell things online on
eBay or Poshmark or Craigslist,
you have to report those profits as income
on your tax return.
Now, the first question you need to answer
is whether your eBay habit
is a business or a hobby.
If you get a steady
profit from your sales,
the IRS will probably
classify this as a business,
but if you're only an occasional seller,
the IRS considers it a hobby.
And in either instance, the
income needs to be reported.
But if your sales are of a business,
then you have the option
of deducting more expenses.
Though, as usual, when
the word IRS is used,
please talk to an accountant
before you do absolutely anything at all.
Have you ever sat down on the sidewalk?
Well, then you have
probably broken the law.
In about 53% of American cities,
you've broken an ordinance
against sitting or lying down in public.
These are known as sit-lie ordinances.
It's controversial to ban people
from hanging out on a sidewalk.
Critics of these laws obviously point out
that these are basically
designed to attack people
experiencing homelessness
and loitering teenagers.
But proponents of the laws say
that they're about keeping
the sidewalks clear
so that people can get through.
Still, sit down at your own peril.
Now, this video isn't over.
I cover a bunch more ways
that you broke the law
over on Nebula, which you can
now get with a huge discount
when you get it with today's
sponsor, CuriosityStream.
Loud pets, simply walking
across the street.
If you play a movie or TV show in public.
Because sometimes going
into detail about every way
that you ever broke the law
doesn't work on YouTube,
which is why my creator
friends and I teamed up
to build our own platform where
creators don't need to worry
about demonetization or
the dreaded algorithm.
It's called Nebula
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with CuriosityStream.
Not only are our Nebula
versions ad free and extended,
but they also get released early
before the YouTube versions,
because Nebula's a place
where we can experiment
with content and put things out
that we couldn't put on YouTube,
and it features lots of YouTube's
top educational-ish creators,
like MKBHD, Philosophy
Tube, and Extra Credits.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with CuriosityStream
because they are the go-to
source best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you will love the stuff
on CuriosityStream.
And we worked out a deal
where if you sign up
for CuriosityStream with
the link in the description,
you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a CuriosityStream member.
And right now CuriosityStream
is offering 26% off
their annual plans, that's less
than $15 for the entire year
for both CuriosityStream and Nebula.
So, if you click on the link
that's on screen right now,
you'll get CuriosityStream
and Nebula for 26% off.
Or you can go to
curiositystream.com/legaleagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content
directly for under $15 per year.
So, just click on this link.
Plus, clicking on this link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist
for all of my other legal
entertainment videos
or I'll see you in court.